this is miserable it's lashing down with
rain and only a few degrees above
freezing but if you want to be tested
for coronavirus in New York you'd better
be prepared to wait what time did you
arrive and it's now it's now 2 o'clock
so you've been here for how you feeling
at the moment the ambulances are coming
in going nonstop we counted 12 in just
half an hour New York is not just the
epicenter of the outbreak in the United
States it's fast becoming the globular
center there are now four times more
cases here in this one city as there are
in the entire UK the number of cases in
New York is doubling every three days
the curve isn't flattening in fact it's
tightening in the words of one official
here
the virus is hitting New York like a
bullet train like everywhere else they
need beds ventilators masks and fast a
convention center in Manhattan is being
turned into an emergency hospital from
there the New York governor delivered
his daily televised press conference and
pleaded for help I need the ventilators
in 14 days only the federal government
has that power
and not to exercise that power it is
inexplicable to me and against this
worsening backdrop Donald Trump is now
saying he hopes to lift the restrictions
and reopen America within just a few
weeks ultimately the goal is to ease the
guidelines and open things up to very
large sections of our country as we near
the end of our historic battle with the
invisible enemy I said earlier today
that I hope we can do this by Easter I
think that would be a great thing for
our country and we're all working very
hard to make that a reality
they reckon it could be just days away
from running out of supplies here
they're trying but they're just not on
top of it and time isn't on their side
and this is just New York just the start
what happens here could ripple across
the entire United States Alister buckle
Sky News New York